craft beer makers go to extraordinary
lengths to brew up the perfect pint and
lately that attention to detail has
shifted on to what is on the outside as
well in a recent USA Today poll readers
named heady topper the winner for the
best beer label Kenneth Craig visited
with beer makers including that labels
creator who are putting a lot of effort
into the art of ale Kenneth good morning
good morning to you Dana we really did
get a rare inside look at the process of
creating this art which for many
breweries has become just as important
as how that beer tastes when it comes to
the art of beer there are few on the
same playing field as heady topper for
years the can has been one of the most
sought-after in the world the double IPA
inside among the highest-rated and its
cover art for craft beer fans among the
most recognizable we really started
looking at the shelves the beer coolers
and you know what made them all similar
and how could we stand out and we
thought if we can you know make a label
that's really authentic and is a
reflection of us and our style that
that's what we wanted to do and did
people react right away when they when
they saw the art on the can Jenna and
John Kim achar the founders of the
alchemist brewery in Vermont and say
that label was a collaboration with
artist and musician dan Blakeslee
[Music]
whose concert posters captured John's
attention at a Vermont coffee shop what
he said to me was he lights the
whimsical nature of it he was hired to
do the art for the brewery and then the
label for heady topper and then the
second one the one we actually used he
was like okay side profile of a guy with
a beard you know that the hops exploding
out of his head everywhere this is one
of the original sketches for heady
topper Blakesley grew a beard and used a
picture of himself as inspiration
turning the vision into reality without
ever tasting the beer you have never had
a sip of one of these beers well I've
had three sips of beer in my life and I
didn't like the number of craft
breweries nationwide has more than
tripled in the past ten years and now
Brewers are not only in a race to make
the best tasting beers they're also
competing for your eye it's a sea of
color and a sea of beautiful artwork I
think the consumer to really wants a
whole experience they want more than
just a great beer they do want a
beautiful can so this one is called
tropical crumble designing those cans
has become a full-time job for Meghan
Penman it's been crazy who has created
more than 300 labels for other half
brewing in Brooklyn New York which
releases upwards of four new cans every
week it's wild to see it out there in
the world and see people with it this is
so many people's dream job with the can
as her canvas her throwback images are
an explosion of color we liked the idea
of this can art feeling kind of 90s like
this reminds me of a shirt I'd wear when
I was in yes exactly like 90s Jam shorts
like Fresh Prince of bel-air like that
kind of a vibe there our entire social
media accounts dedicated to the craft of
craft beer labels more than 150,000
followers track other half and its art
on the breweries Instagram account and
the most die-hard fans will line the
street to get their hands on its latest
creation
right now we're canning up a batch
hot showers Sam Richardson is one of
other haps founders and it's brewmaster
we have a language across all of our
cans I think they all look different but
I think that you can see the connections
you can look at and say that's that's
another half label do you think you
would have the type of popularity and
cult following that you do if you didn't
have this kind of art I don't think so
what do you think it does take to stand
out right now quality quality can you
see it you walk into a shop and you see
all that artwork it's not art you know
you might buy a can of something because
of the art once but if that beer is
terrible you're never the art doesn't
matter what the art is if you're not
going to come back because the beer is
not good you want the the beers flying
this way right so the team at the
alchemist has continued their work with
Dan Blakeslee on other cans since the
release of their famed beer and are
currently redesigning the label for an
IPA named rapture they say their art and
beer have always gone hand in hand the
coolest thing about being a part of the
craft beer revolution right now is the
high level of competitiveness because
everyone is really being forced to set
themselves apart we make the best beer
we can we have the best artists we can
work with but we don't take ourselves
too seriously at the end of the day it's
beer
you know the artists we spoke to told me
as an artist the dream really is to have
people see their work so for them the
fact that thousands and thousands of
people now know their art from these
cans really is more than they could ask
for and we couldn't go to these amazing
breweries of course and not bring back
oh we love looking at their work we also
love drinking yeah I thought it was a
really good point I've picked wine
before by the label I would pick beer by
the label but they're right I wouldn't
go back to it right if what was inside
if we don't like what does Michelle have
she's got one from the other half and
you've got one from the other well this
is one of their new releases and I've
got another I've got focal banger and
this is also from the outcomes yeah so
they're our sketches and then they're
these really cool here we go I mean
because I would be
okay Cheers hey-oh cheers Cheers
labels and liquids yeah